robert spencer many experts are now
concerned that
untold numbers of jihadis are slipping
through with the hundreds of thousands
of unvetted immigrants at the southern
border are you concerned
sure uh
what's to keep them
they can read the news as well as
anybody else they know that the southern
border is essentially open
and we've already seen it just a few
months ago there were two yemenis who
were on the terror watch list who were
apprehended at the border first thing if
they were apprehended how many more got
through without being apprehended
not only that but then i see the the
border customs and border patrol
put out a press release saying that
they'd been apprehended and the next day
it had been taken down
after the story was widely reported it
looked as if the biden administration
was trying to cover up the fact that
terrorists are already exploiting the
southern border and that was months ago
we don't know how many have come in
since then